[Music]
this
is what facebook's offices normally look
like expansive spaces
with plenty of areas to meet and rows of
desks
open office style something ceo mark
zuckerberg showed off after the new
silicon valley headquarters opened in
2015.
it's uh we've worked like this for a
long time and it's been
a pretty core way uh for for how we we
do what we do here at facebook
facebook's new new york offices should
look just as bustling
instead they're full of empty chairs and
vacant conference rooms
the only workers around are the ones
building out the company's more than two
million square feet of leased
office space on the west side of
manhattan
but employees have yet to move in
i think that it's quite possible that
over the next five to ten years
about 50 percent of our people could be
working remotely
facebook shifted to remote work early in
the pandemic and was one of the first to
lay out a plan for some employees to
work from home
indefinitely we are seeing that
productivity has actually been
really solid working remotely but i
think there no matter what is going to
be
some type of future where we are seeing
the value in both remote and in office
work
even as facebook has been preparing for
a more flexible future
it has been expanding physical space in
new york signing a major lease during
the pandemic to become one of the city's
largest corporate tenants
so why is facebook doubling down on
in-person work in new york
and what impact could its growing
presence have on the future of tech in
the city
facebook first came to new york in 2007
opening its office with a handful of
people focused on marketing and
advertising
becca foy who now heads facebook's
business teams in new york
was one of the office's earliest
employees i joined the company when we
were
less than 500 people globally less than
20 or so here in new york
and now we are over 4 000 employees
half of which are tech and engineering
then in 2019
facebook signed a lease in hudson yards
a new development in the city
that deal roughly tripled facebook
square footage in new york
in 2020 in the midst of the pandemic
facebook again
expanded its footprint in the city
adding an additional 730
000 square feet of space in the former
farley post office building
the largest single lease signed in
manhattan last year
the companies go where the people they
want to hire are
facebook doubling down in new york sends
a really
loud message that the people they want
to hire are in new york
located just down the street from hudson
yards the space at farley post
gives facebook something that's a little
bit more silicon valley than new york
city
a kind of campus as we think about this
urban campus and really growing the
footprint
you know it's it's absolutely vital to
the future for a few reasons not only do
we need to accommodate our growing
number of employees but really
accommodate the needs and the
preferences of how they're going to work
most effectively
the completed spaces look like many of
facebook's other offices
with open office seating and a variety
of meeting rooms
and for the floor is still under
construction you can imagine spaces that
are
right for events having collaboration
areas you know with creative agencies
etc
and so our business teams are really
going to look to hudson yards as their
hub
as we reopen those offices and then on
the flip side
the farley post building that is really
going to become more of a dedicated tech
hub for
our tech and engineering teams despite
the pandemic voice says facebook didn't
make any major structural changes to its
office designs
facebook doesn't plan to reopen until it
sees it as safe to do so
but that's a matter of when not if when
we do open our offices the health and
safety piece is going to be our number
one priority and so if you imagine
walking into the offices i can't predict
exactly what that will look like
but i know that we will take those
protocols and just the experience of
coming into the building
really seriously there's
been plenty of being spilled and in all
kinds of newspapers and magazines about
how
people are just leaving new york city in
droves but actually we're not really
seeing that in tech
julie samuels is the executive director
at tech nyc
a coalition of about 800 tech companies
and investors working on behalf of the
industry at the city and state level
she says the industry has fared well
during the pandemic as it was already
more set up for working from home
but she doesn't think that shift will
push firms out of new york
i think that the tech sector is
fundamentally committed to the city
i think however the tech sector
generally speaking
is much more kind of open-minded about
where it works and how it works
though smaller tech firms aren't taking
direction from facebook the major leases
it and other big tech firms signed in
2020
could influence tech's future in the
city what's going to happen is people
are going to go work at facebook
uh they're gonna learn about tech and
honestly
i mean i love i love facebook but like i
hope a bunch of them leave and i hope
that they start
their own companies it's like that's
that's the magic
for facebook when exactly workers will
return to work
is unclear but foy says a majority of
employees
have expressed the desire to come back
mark zuckerberg
you know we'll say some of our products
and things that we're building they can
happen in a matter of months
but building a culture happens day by
day over years
over decades and having our offices and
our physical locations are going to
continue to be such a contributor to our
culture
you